sí muy buenas tardes pues fue el
presidente de la conferencia episcopal
de francia monseñor enrique mulambo fue
quien hizo estas declaraciones diciendo
que efectivamente los obispos del país
determinaban que si había una
responsabilidad de la iglesia como
institución en todos estos casos de
pedofilia aceptaban además que había
digamos una dimensión sistémica de estos
crímenes en el seno de la iglesia y
también explicó el que consideraba que
había un cierto número de un contexto
general una cierta mentalidad en el seno
de esta institución que había permitido
que se diera en este tipo de vejámenes
por parte de sus religiosos hacia los
menores de edad en estos momentos en
lourdes pues toda esta semana están
reunidos los 120 obispos del país en esa
reunión que realizan cada año y pues
están sobre todo centrándose en este
informe de las comisiones sube este
informe que fue entregado en octubre que
estuvo investigando durante varios años
los abusos sexuales en el seno de la
iglesia católica francesa en los últimos
70 años
y pues según este informe unas 216 mil
personas fueron víctimas de abusos
sexuales cuando eran menores de edad una
cifra que llega incluso a ser hasta más
de 300.000 si se tiene en cuenta
personas vinculadas a la iglesia pero
sin ningún cargo dentro del clérigo
además de esto pues monseñor emulando
fuego también dijo que en vista a esto
la iglesia pues también tenía un deber
de justicia y de reparación hacia las
víctimas víctimas que de hecho fueron
invitadas a esta reunión en lourdes pero
la mayoría de ellas declinaron la
invitación porque querían que toda esta
semana de conferencia pues estuviera
centrada únicamente sobre este informe
sobre la pedofilia en todo caso esta
reunión episcopal se termina el día
lunes en la ciudad de lourdes allí habrá
el discurso de clausura del presidente
de la conferencia episcopal seguramente
estaremos muy atentos de lo que él pueda
decir ahí para saber finalmente que más
decisiones han tomado los 120 prelados
reunidos allí